[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships rachel cruz number
one best-selling author ramsey
personality my daughter is my co-host
today open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're gonna start this hour with marie
in detroit hi marie welcome to the
ramsay show
hi how are you thank you for taking my
call
um
here's my question i am trying to
figure out how like
what the process is for paying like the
the principal
uh the extra payments and all of that so
that i can pay my car off early um i
have a
75 month loan
my interest rate uh is 13.74
yes i know that's a horrible interest
rate i
literally when i bought the car the car
i drove into the dealership with would
not have made it out the dealership so i
literally had to take what i could get
in that emergency moment
and i've accessed like the i did like a
amortization calculator if i'm saying it
right
and
i
i if i pay everything as is right now
i'm gonna pay like eleven thousand
dollars in interest on a twenty thousand
dollar car which is stupid crazy
and i've been trying to piece together
by watching youtube videos and asking
questions
what is the exact process that i can
take to pay extra on my car towards my
principal towards my interest or that
that whole process that allows you to
pay your car off
before time and i and i i can't figure
out how to piece everything together to
get a straight answer so i feel it's a
blessing that i was even able to get
through to you um so i just wanna i'm
gonna shut up and listen and listen
way to go marie
way to go you're doing so good you're
thinking outside the box what's the
total balance of the car if you paid it
off today
um eighteen thousand one hundred and
some odd dollars i've only had the car a
couple years okay and what do you make a
year
um a little over one hundred 000 and
that's only recently i was not making
that much money over a year ago and i
buttoned down and got another job and my
debt i bring home about 4 900 a month
and my debt is about 3 500 a month
you're
getting a big tax refund
um no because i have tax debt that i'm
actually tackling as well i'm trying to
get all my finances in order and trying
to become debt free okay how much is
your money going into your 401k
yes i do but i don't have the max i i
have um i think about five percent
gotcha okay all right
well um
you're you're new to all of our stuff i
i do want to answer your question but i
want to answer it in context
of what we teach okay
so we teach a whole process for becoming
wealthy
and the shortest distance between where
you are in wealth is getting rid of this
debt as you said
the irs and the car debt and whatever
other debt you've got we teach you to
list all of that debt smallest to
largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one and attack
the little one with a vengeance
so let's put that in context of that
what do you owe the uh the kgb i mean
the irs
um i just actually did it and i'm at
about
twenty thousand okay so very similar to
your car okay what other debts have you
got
besides my car
um i think i have a few medical bills i
don't have a i guess in context an
enormous amount of debt but the debt
that i had you got plenty if i was to
lose one of my jobs you got money
literally you got enough you got enough
to be nervous
well she just said if she lost one of
her jobs she drowned yeah so yeah you
feel it
good
do you know what the other medical debt
is you have credit cards too marie at
all credit card debt i no i don't have
credit card debt no student loan
no good okay great okay we got a good
picture then okay so what we would do is
tell you to do this temporarily
stop investing
because we want to completely focus on
clearing all this debt as fast as
possible and i want to squeeze as much
out of your check and get it home as
much as i can
to throw it at the debts first thing
we're gonna do is knock out those two
little medical bills right quick because
they're just like mosquitoes buzzing
around okay
and then once they're done then i agree
with you we'll pay the minimum pay are
you paying a payment plan on your old
tax debt
um i haven't gotten to that point yet
i'm actually working with a financial
counselor who's going to do an offer and
compromise for me once the irs sends me
my official bill you won't get it if you
paid him to do that
um i paid i paid them to file all of my
back year taxes that's what i paid them
to do yeah do not pay for an offering
compromise you won't get one
okay the oic is based on the only way
the irs forgives irs debt an offering
compromise is with the irs waives your
debt forget they give it up they're not
going to collect it the only way they do
that is if you are uh have no income and
no assets
and you have both so there's not a
chance you're gonna get an oic and some
of these companies i don't know who
you're dealing with will charge as much
as ten thousand dollars like you hear
them on cable
tv and stuff like if you got irs debt we
can help yeah give me ten thousand
dollars to file an oic and you don't
stand a snowball's chance in hell of
that thing going through so no don't do
it um
you're not you're not going to get
approved for it that's it so now uh back
to your car that you called out okay all
the way back there we're going to stop
your 401k we're going to pay minimums on
everything we're going to attack the
debt as fast and as harshly as we can if
you can change your w-2 and bring more
home and not create more tax problems
but instead just not get a tax refund
because the tax refund is going to go
straight to them
okay but if you could get no tax refund
but oh no more and i think you've got
too much coming out of your check and
and i would have your tax person look at
that but anyway as much as we can do
anything we can do to get money throw at
the car now then there's two types of
car loans
most car loans are what are called
simple interest loans and you would just
simply
pay
big chunks of extra checks once a month
on that debt
so if you send them a thousand dollars
the next month that 13.74 is not charged
on that thousand dollars
okay and you went from 18 to 17.
and then you send them a thousand
dollars the next it goes from 17 to 16.
i want you to pay off this car
in 12 months 1500 a month or less
12 or less at 1500 including my the the
actual payment no on top of your on top
of your actual payment
okay and you'll be done actually you'll
be done in about 11 months if you do
that
okay okay now that's if it's simple
interest and most car loans
90 some odd percent of them are simple
interest there is another type of
interest that is a rip-off car loan a
sub-prime lender and it's a high
interest rate you might have one of
those
and they will charge you the interest
whether you pay it off early or not
they calculated they give you some
savings but they calculated on total of
payments the top
when you call them up and ask for the
balance what do they give you they give
you the eighteen thousand balance or
they give you the thirty thousand dollar
balance
i honestly i keep getting the runaround
i can't get anybody to answer my
question who's the loan with
nice ally oh crap yeah you may have a
sub prime loan here allies crappy stuff
so 13 points you still just throw more
money at it either way just throw as
much as you can at it as fast as you can
and you just send them extra check once
a month a big one
and tell them principle only and they'll
throw it on there it is that simple
after all that discussion
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today she and george campbell
will join me on july the 14th we are
hosting a free live stream event called
the real estate reality check
and we're going to walk you through
what's going on out here in the housing
market and how it all works and how to
navigate it and spoiler alert the
housing market is not going to crash and
we're going to show you why we'll teach
you where real estate prices come from
and uh so then we can show you how that
works and you can understand the facts
with actual data and charts and graphs
and economics and stuff instead of
feelings
yeah
if you want some feelings read the
comments on my instagram you'll find
some feelings
people have a lot of feelings on
instagram i did this morning
i don't know you posted the it's a great
synopsis you like the article yeah that
was great of it
and then underneath
here it goes
it's a lot
i know i hate to even
you finish
dave reads mean tweets right i mean we
ought to do some of that but anyway but
if that's what you if that's what you're
reading though and that's where you're
getting your information though it is it
is scary
of what people are saying of like the
the belief of what is really happening
in the world the number of people that
think that the sky is falling is
disturbing it's a lot i mean it's a lot
they're angry about it and they try to
be intellectual about their anger
and it's really hilarious it's kind of
sad
but let me help you with something okay
if you if you are posting negative
comments on someone else's instagram
that you don't even know
by definition you're not an intellectual
okay
by definition you know more than half
the population well i mean people feel
they need no way i i don't i don't i
guess i don't qualify because i've never
posted a comment on someone's instagram
that i don't know good or bad well of
course not you
i'm just gonna say yeah
i don't need to go around and [ __ ]
about what someone else has to say oh my
gosh you've said two cuss words in two
segments of this show already
unbelievable okay no but really
but people are
they are scary they're afraid they are
and in their fear they come off angry
that is true and we're going to help the
question
the statement is that you don't need to
be afraid and here are the facts and
this is what we're going to talk about
which i really am excited about we're
going to help
we're going to show you that
yeah yeah we're gonna help and you can
call me names and everything else i'm
still gonna help you that's right you're
so sweet that's me
sweet that's what i'm known for but we
can all acknowledge though
this is i mean if you were to paint
where we are
as a country today from
inflation
to
i mean everything that's going on right
yeah i tried i put filled up my raptor
and i almost passed out it fee i'm a
hyper ventilator i had a john deloney
anxiety attack you did that's good to
know he's human it's not because i it's
not because i don't have money it just
smears it just made me mad i know but it
is pretty wild where we're at though as
a country would you agree of everything
or do you just don't think it's like
it is it is um with housing there is
more negativity right now in the
economic news than there has been in a
decade yes okay yeah yeah and so if this
is your first grown-up decade to have a
grown-up economic trouble this is your
first time to see this i've lived
through like six of these
so i've got a bit of a yawn
but it's not because i'm detached or
don't understand i just have perspective
i'm old
and so i've just not i've seen that we
didn't die from this the other six times
it happened in my life and so
it's not the end of the world the sky is
not falling
i mean biden's incompetent but he
doesn't have the power to completely
destroy the nation
he's just screwing it up you know i mean
it's not it's not he just doesn't and
neither does the fed and neither do i if
i'm wrong about this woo
you know and so you know it's just the
the point is it's that we're going to be
okay and we're going to give you
perspective over time and it's not
because we're out of touch it's actually
because we're in touch with this thing
called history and data and perspective
and all of that leads to a word called
wisdom
and we're going to walk you through all
of that and it's going to be we're going
to talk down to people it's just we're
gonna show you what's going on yeah and
it's just but it it is a little bit of a
psychologically fascinating thing in the
world of social media how
out of control people's emotions are i
mean they're four years old in their
emotions
just completely bonkers yes you would
not i would not anymore allow you to
behave like that in my
presence
and you wouldn't either you wouldn't
either i mean if i want you that lady
sitting out there wouldn't allow someone
to act like that in front of her
because she would be going you're four
years old
you know grow up
and because people don't act like that
in person but they're on digital media
they lose them
but with the event though we are going
to address
the the real estate prices that and the
in the fear and the like the yeah yeah
the mindset that's so easy to go into
right
and if you've already got your mind made
up and you've decided the world's coming
to an end don't watch it it's just going
to make you mad because i'm right and
you're wrong it's going to piss you off
so don't don't even what percentage do
you know you are right that the world is
that that the real estate market is not
versus the commenters on instagram a
hundred
but in general in general hey listen
okay did you did i call inflation a year
ago you did dead on yeah you did you did
did i call the recession properly in
2008. i have no idea no i did not
okay i declared there was not going to
be a recession in 2008 and i was wrong
it went down okay all right all right
now but i was using it i was using
different data to analyze that than i
was this situation that was more
that did i catch everyone off guard
though or am i i mean i was that was the
first time that type of economy
movement had occurred and that none of
that is involved in this one yes okay it
was the mortgage-backed securities the
nbs's and the uh uh
the mortgages being made to broke people
because of horrible lending practices
bought by hedge funds and securitized
and it crashed not only the stock market
it crashed the housing market so uh
didn't crash it brought it down
dramatically and it all came back in 24
months by the way yeah even in 2008 when
i was wrong yeah and so if i'm really
wrong on this one
we got two years this idea that this
idea that your world is coming to an end
is still
not correct i'm more right than that no
matter what we are we it's not just me i
mean you and me and george oh you've got
all of us have gone through all this
stuff you've done this since you were 18
dave i have i have ramseysolutions.com
realitycheck if you want to sign up for
the free live stream
called real estate reality check and as
you can tell the discussion between
george and rachel and i will be
fun and entertaining it always is all
right zach is with us in chicago hey
zach welcome to the ramsay show
thank you dave thank you rachel for
taking my call sure what's up
uh so i've been on your program for
about three years now and i am debt free
except for my mortgage
um i am
thank you i am yeah no thank you good
day
providing this knowledge and rachel um
the
next step here in my life is i'm getting
married in november
congratulations zach
thank you thank you and i have a new
problem that i never thought about
before they so kind of took me off off
guard and i don't know how to handle it
uh the the wedding is a traditional
indian wedding
and you know we're cash flowing all of
it mainly her parents and my parents so
that's not the issue
the issue is they're insisting on
gifting
us a bunch of gold both of us from both
sides
my side to hers her size to us
because that's what they do is tradition
what the hell am i going to do with a
bunch of gold sitting in a safe for the
next 30 30 years because i asked my dad
dad where's your gold that you got it
from your wedding it's been sitting in a
safe deposit box for 40 years
what am i supposed to do
what am i supposed to do
well it's tradition that's my thing zach
a little bit there's like there's like a
how fun
yeah yeah it's it's exciting but i'm
like i don't know how much how much do
you think all this gold will be worth
uh
i would if i was put a number on it i
mean we probably i'm gonna end up with
like fifty thousand dollars wow okay
so how long before you sell it
exactly
i mean the the problem i'm having with
it also is my family's going spending
and paying 10 to 13
on tax for buying this gold yeah you
know that's money that i don't get
it's not that's not your problem that's
their problem
so i would take the gold and i would
hold it long enough to hurt as few
feelings as possible like a year
and then i would sell it turn it into
cash that's simple and it's a nice gift
a fifty thousand dollar gift of any kind
that i can sell later for fifty thousand
dollars is a wonderful not hurting
people's feelings holding off to her as
least
something's happening i feel it i feel
it in the air
[Music]
changing before our eyes dave you're
changing oh
yeah that's it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
on
the stage the debt free stage brandon
and blair are with us right here in the
lobby hey guys how are you hey
subtle shirts
we just wanted to make sure the point
got across make sure it's bright you
need like lit up debt free
i like it i like your shirts a lot i'm
kidding with you i love them so how much
debt did you pay off
we paid off
230 000 wow in 38 months good for you
and your range of income during that
time we started off with
126 000 and ended with 170 000.
excellent what do y'all do for a living
i'm a teacher take what grade you teach
second grade i love it
sweet time sweet kids yes and i'm an
implementation manager for a financial
institution very cool very cool we got
some second graders running around among
them
we love second grade teachers right now
we know how patient they must be
so good stuff guys so where do you all
live
greensboro north carolina
very fun what kind of debt was the 230
000
it was a little bit of everything dave
uh we didn't meet a zero percent
interest card that we didn't love
so we had all sorts of consumer debt uh
from beds to furniture to
appliances car loans student loans were
the biggest we even had a house that we
decided to keep for a while and ended up
getting rid of okay that was your
personal residence or your rental it it
was uh
it was a second home at that time yeah
oh i see okay so you still got your
house and you correct now does this
include your mortgage
one of them it includes okay but you
still have a mortgage on your resume
all right cool cool
yeah that's a lot you guys you were
normal we were very very normal yeah
normal sucks yeah way to go guys
so proud of y'all tell us how you did
this well how'd you get tied into this
ramsey stuff and how did this journey
start so um
at one point i was doing like a
makeshift budget
and
i realized that we didn't have very much
money left over at the end of the month
and we had this nine-year-old and no way
to pay for college
and so it just it really hit hard and we
looked at you know how many debts we
actually had and we had i think about 18
different people we owed money to
and that like really hit hard that the
majority of our paycheck was going to
debt so
i remember telling brandon we've got to
do something we've got to figure
something out and so i googled how to
get out of debt and baby step 2 snowball
popped up and so i clicked on it and
i immediately was like this is a great
plan and he's our spender and so i did
not think that he was going to get on
board
and then i realized that was baby step
two so i kept looking and saw that there
were seven baby steps and brandon agreed
to do it
i did not think it was going to stick
and then the next day he came home
and he was so excited and he said oh my
gosh there's a podcast and you've got to
listen to it and there's even people who
will get on and they'll scream that
they're debt free and it's super
exciting and we were hooked from there i
love it um
sneaking in there yes oh my gosh okay so
what did that conversation look like
because there's a lot of people
listening that are like oh you know it's
the wife and she's like i want to get my
husband on board what did she say
brandon that kind of made you
that kind of hooked you that made you
even look up a podcast that you kind of
like okay i'm intrigued by this idea of
actually becoming debt free
it was that budget sitting down and
looking and realizing we make a decent
amount of money
but
it we can't enjoy it it's it's gone
before it even hits it's just kind of
like
we make six figures we're broke yeah
it's very frustrating and and then to
to see the little one here uh nine and
and not know how we were even gonna
think about college at that point um
i felt like we were letting letting her
down so we needed to get get
get kicking into gear good dad that's
amazing that's good yeah there's nothing
like the uh changing your family tree to
motivate you if that's real
you look in their eyes and you go i have
to be a grown-up and i'm going to fix
this mess you know you got that's good
guys i'm very proud of you
so what were the things you guys did
to get the most progress when getting
out of that would you say
um well i took on quite a few different
little side gigs i did a lot of tutoring
which brought in quite a bit of money um
what can you get an hour tutoring i did
about 35 an hour yeah what was the main
subject um reading reading yeah i love
it and then i also it's also by the way
very helpful for the parent yeah
yes
and whenever my county offered like any
kind of training and they would pay us
to do it i went through the training so
even if it didn't really apply
necessarily i still did it because they
were paying me for it and so that
definitely helped
nice part-time jobs yes and we also sold
his truck sold the truck down oh man oh
now i got real yeah
what was the truck it was a ram 1500
brand new at the time whoa
what did that sell for
uh we just sold that a couple years ago
so it sold for around 20. yeah
it's a beast of a truck yeah
oh man that was a hard one yeah good
news is if you drive like no one else
later you can drive anything you want
we're gonna get there you're on your way
yeah way to go guys wow that that was
they you guys are committed
you you deserve a big bold shirt
yeah
you were committed i mean you you did
the hard stuff the hard work and
everything else so at the end of the day
when someone hears you paid off 230 230
000 in 38 months a little over three
years that's a rowdy number sold the
truck uh sounded like you sold a second
house or a third house or whatever it
was and uh so you moved some stuff but
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
i'll let you go first okay
it to me to me it's the budget
it uh it allows the spenders to spend it
gives you permission i feel you brandon
that's right yeah it gives the savers a
little a little control over us yeah so
i think that's really important
um and
when murphy calls because it's going to
call along the way especially over 38
months and i know others have done
longer journeys
you have to start with taking debt off
the table it's really easy to say let's
let's go grab some more debt but when
you make that decision to take debt off
the table
you you you
find other other solutions on how to do
things yeah and then for me
it's all about changing your mindset
you have to realize one that you're not
a victim
um that was really big for me because
i'm like oh poor teacher can't get ahead
you know we don't make a lot took out
all these loans but then i had to
realize no i took out these loans this
is my fault now let's get out and then
to also realize that you're not the
exception there's a lot of people who
say oh well but my story is different
and so i can take the debt out or you
know i can use a card here because this
is a different situation and you are not
the exception to the rule
your plan works and so you if you follow
it and you do it correctly it works for
anyone
can you guys fill in for me when i'm out
they got this dialed in i mean that's
good right there that'll preach amazing
amazing stuff very very good good job so
proud of y'all hey we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story you will be
baby steps millionaires the third most
likely career to become a millionaire as
a teacher
so you are on the list right there right
up there at the top very very good and a
copy of total money makeover for you to
give away to someone we'll also give you
a one-year membership to the brand new
financial peace university new videos
with george camel chris hogan dr john
not chris hogan i'm sorry
rachel cruz and chris was in it yeah and
rachel cruz and dr john deloney in it
and me of course so brand new videos all
out right now with ramsey plus financial
peace university and that'll give you
something to give away or if you hadn't
ever been through it time to go through
it did y'all ever go through it we did
okay whenever um when we were pregnant
and um we were about to have the baby
you had done a trial where you could do
it for free during covid yeah and so we
binge watched all the videos
good i love it very good anyway so yeah
we just sat there and might as well yeah
guys i have something to do it's either
that or tiger king so
good job you guys good job all right
brandon and blair and bring in madison
and rowan with us from greensboro north
carolina 230 000 paid off in 38 months
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
retro crews ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free
free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time you'll save even
more always use the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from robert in
kentucky i used to be a business owner
and my minor children were on the
payroll for modeling on our website and
doing commercials
their pay was just enough to fully fund
their roth iras
now i have sold my business so they know
so they no longer receive w-2s can i
fund their iras by having them do chores
around the house if i keep track of the
chores
and the amounts paid no no
won't survive an audit so um you have to
have an earned income to fund an ira and
you have to file a tax return on the
earned income
and um
no you can't uh
have them work for you now what you can
do and what i did with rachel daniel and
denise
was that any work that they did at the
office like you had done i mean we
didn't do any modeling but um we had you
selling books at the uh you were the
cute kid selling books at the book table
but uh you actually did work your little
tail off uh and um
so we we paid you
well for that
kept track of that and um and then i
added up anything that you all made
outside of our home babysitting
uh dog sitting
yard cutting whatever but integrity
snacks had to be something outside of
our home you cannot pay a kid for doing
chores and file taxes on but you can
do that if they work uh doing something
outside the home because someone else
has paid them and is an income and then
you file that income
and pay income tax on
the income if it's taxable in that
situation if there's enough there and
whatever that amount totals up to
up to the maximum on the roth ira you
can put in so like i remember one year
one kid made like 123 dollars
and we added it all up and that's all we
could
uh
with integrity
before god
tell the irs that they had really made
we don't we didn't lie about it in other
words and so i filed tax return on that
kid twelve hundred twenty three dollars
and i opened a roth ira now i paid the
taxes this is a 14 year old or something
you know i paid the taxes
and i put the money into the roth ira
the 1200 bucks into the roth ira but it
enabled me to where you guys all came
out of college with a pretty good amount
it wasn't like 200 000 or something but
it was a it was north of 50 grand
probably and that they had all grown to
and you've done them a little bit at a
time from the time you're about 10
up through 18 or whatever and we file
tax returns on you every year
and so that you have proof that there's
an earned income
so that when you file it now if you
don't file the tax return
you're going to get in trouble and if
you can't justify
proof that there's no words you can't
you can't have someone
come to your office and do modeling and
pay them eight hundred thousand dollars
when you could have hired another model
for two thousand dollars
you can't do that okay you have to has
to be market value for the labor now it
can be the upper end of market value for
the labor but
you know so uh when you guys did work
here at the office in the summers we did
we paid you well
so that we could fund that thing but we
didn't pay you like 5x of what we would
pay someone else because you can't that
won't survive an audit it's not it's
didn't have it's not a marketplace wage
and so that's how you can do that but
it's a good it's a good question and
it's what uh baby step seven that's
where you would do stuff like that you
would not do that if you don't have your
mortgage paid off yeah you pay your
mortgage off you would not do that while
you're putting more than you put more
than 15 percent away for retirement you
would not do that while you haven't
funded the kids college fund and instead
you funded the roth ira you would not do
that so this is all after
everything else is done house is paid
off at baby step six
now we're just loading up anything we
can load up and that sets the kid up and
wow and you know realistically they can
be millionaires well before they're 30
if they stay out of debt don't have
college debt because of you and you do
stuff like that because of you
and then they come into their first home
and you're able to help with that
because of you you do all of those kinds
of things you could set that if the kids
got their head screwed on sure you know
then then they can come out the math
comes out really well in their favor
well and it's just and it's the
intentionality and i feel like that's
a little bit of that idea like when
people say like
the rich get richer kind of thing right
like it's a different mindset but when
you have the mindset of baby step seven
when you don't when you as a person you
have no payments your house is paid off
you're funding college it almost gives
you the bandwidth to think okay how can
i continue to change my family tree what
is what is that
how do you continue to pass on not just
the the monetary side of it
but also the character side of holding
it yeah you teach them the hard work
ethic and uh saving and generosity
versus a home where nothing is ever
talked about you're just you know i mean
and this isn't a conversation there's no
teaching there's no guiding there's
nothing
then your child has to start from ground
zero as an adult
probably getting themselves out of debt
and trying to figure this out right so
it's just the whole changing your family
tree it's it's a it's a it's a big scope
a big scope
yeah it is it's more holistic than
simply the math totally yeah
that's what you're saying for sure yeah
and you're right it is the answer
because i didn't grow up in a rich
household i mean we weren't poor i
didn't go without food or anything but
we weren't rich i mean we knew those
rich people lived over there you know
and so uh when when i decided i was
gonna be as come a student of rich
people uh the rich get richer is is how
the that's how people that are mad about
it always say ah the rich get richer
part get power yeah yeah because they
keep doing rich people stuff
which is intentionality it's not
screwing people they just think about it
when you know the way i grew up you
wouldn't have thought about doing
something like fund the kids roth ira we
weren't even funding our own roth iras
but let's talk about funding some
12-year-old's roth ira right that's a
that's an intentional like you said this
intentionality well and you have the
bandwidth mentally to say you're not
worried about you know putting food on
the table and paying the bill next month
when you're out of that mindset
something happens when you don't have
debt you have an emergency fund you
follow this plan
there is a
a shift i think that you just you have
the capacity in your mind to start
thinking okay what else can we do
creatively to
to help our family well it opens up both
investing and generosity yes because
you've got the bandwidth and the
bandwidth doesn't come from more money
the bandwidth comes from being on a
budget right
and when these folks say you know what
got you out of debt i always i always
say the budget everybody says the budget
the budget because what the budget does
is you're telling your money what to do
instead of wondering where it went and
no one tells money to do something
stupid on purpose but we've all done
something stupid with money because we
didn't bother to tell it what to do yes
and so when you're thinking about it
like that that's what rich people do yes
do you ever recommend utmost still
utmost do i recommend them yeah you can
do them it's just an account in the
kid's name but i know would you it
doesn't grow tax-free right so would you
recommend parents let's just say you
have parents listening on baby step
seven
go that hey
kid work work work we're going to file
taxes on you we're going to do the roth
ira route that's more better i would do
the roth and i would do a 529 for
college yes those are before i did yes
that those are yeah but in better favor
for the child long term right well the
ut my uniform transfer to miners is
simply any account in the kid's name
yeah if you open a savings account at
the bank it's an atma yeah technically
under the law it just means because kids
aren't if you're not 21 or not 18 in
some states you can't do contracts so
you can't open a bank account so your
parents open it in your name and they
are named the custodian and that is an
atma but that happens with a mutual fund
or technically a 529 is it falls under
that because i've heard of some parents
doing that instead of call instead of
like an esa or 529 yeah but they're not
getting the tax break yeah
and so no you're missing out on the free
tax growth tax-free growth is not enough
money so no i wouldn't do that i would
do the 529s first
but everybody's always trying to game
the system so instead just bother to
care
and that game's the system that's what
rich people do rich people are not
consumed with money they're not greedy
it's just they are students of it
rather than students of victimhood now
some poor people are poor
not because of their
uh
bad habits some people are poor because
they're in a situation where they're
being oppressed by another people group
in some way and so poor people are often
taken advantage of and it keeps them
poor and that's that's not good i mean
we never endorse that but but you know
every time i have done something stupid
with money it made me more poor
you lost money you know that goes with
the part of it is that okay part of it
is you're doing stupid stuff with money
and part of it is just the evil that is
in the world that you know payday
lenders taking advantage of people right
that kind of stuff and you don't see
payday lenders in the rich into town
there's a reason
rich people don't do that stuff that's
how they got rich
there's that thing okay so that puts
this hour of the ramsey show in the box
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
can be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help folks build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jeff starts off this hour in
indianapolis hi jeff how are you
doing great thanks for taking my call
today sure what's up
so my wife and i are on baby steps four
five and six we have three kids a senior
in high school a sophomore and an eighth
grader
and we have a pretty good retirement um
built up
and we have about 130
000 left on our mortgage and we were
just wondering you know what what kind
of as our next step
um
you know how do we how do we split
or do we split our money or do we kind
of focus it in one of those three areas
um over the next six years
college is coming at you like a freight
train huh
yes sir
dude what do you have saved for that
jeff
so
we have about
10 for each kid and probably 20.
for our oldest
we think that
her college will probably be between 5
and 10 with her guaranteed scholarships
to an in-state school
so we could
essentially finance that
pretty pretty easily what's your
household income over the next
um it's usually around 120 this year
it'll probably be up to 160. way to go
good okay
well it sounds like you're making good
college choices um in terms of choosing
one that's affordable that's very wise
um
if i woke up in your shoes the college
would be my first concern
but it doesn't necessarily mean that it
has to get all the math
i just want to make sure that that box
is checked and i've got a way to do it
before i move on to something otherwise
i wouldn't pay extra on the house till i
knew i had the kids covered
okay that's why it's five instead of six
yeah what about throwing more into
retirement because the market's on sale
that'd be tempting but be tempting but
before i did that i won't take care of
my kids college
15 of your income going into retirement
and then let's i would that's why it's
four and then five is kids college and
um
you know now if you if you have said
okay we make 160 and we can cash flow
this if we do this this and this then a
b and c then go do a b and c
and cash flow it and that's the kid
getting scholarships college choice kids
going to work while they're in school
none of those are bad things it's not
child abuse
so
but but i want to know that we have a
way mathematically
figured out and it's not just we hope we
can do it we've actually calculated it
out projected the budget out and said
this is how the math is going to flow
for each of the three kids to get
through school once you've got that
then i would move and start paying off
my house yeah then the wiggle room
starts to happen once you have mapped it
out and i think that that's a powerful
thing too jeff of what he just said
though when you put facts on paper like
when you and your wife sit down and you
guys just plan out hey in the next five
years
here's what 22 23 24 25 look like
and project out whether it's income but
the big chunks and you start to see it
then then that kind of gives you more
breathing room to be like okay
we'll set that track going and then
we're going to take this money over here
and we feel good about throwing that
extra on the house because we know that
that's taken care of but it just gives
you kind of that peace of mind and
answers the question
because you guys may look down and be
like oh
gosh like you know because of the kids
college maybe we we pause on paying off
the house early yeah uh maybe not for a
little bit
you may not be able to pay extra
especially when like uh like how old's
the youngest one
uh he's an eighth grader
okay so you're you're gonna have two in
max at the same time but you're gonna
have several years of two people on the
payroll
absolutely yeah so you can you can map
that cash flow out
over the next eight years right
and so um
you know that that's you like just
exactly like rachel's saying there and
you can just put the it won't take an
hour i mean you sit down and do it turn
tv off and just lay it out on the yellow
pad
it's not hard but you you're good but in
that you're going to make assumptions
about where they're going to school and
so you can go and start communicating to
all three of them
this is where you're going to school
yeah
which is exactly what we do the boundary
conversation yeah
or if you want to go somewhere else you
gotta you gotta
uh pay the difference which was a
conversation
we had so the other the other option is
do we try to hammer down on the mortgage
and get it paid off in three years and
then
you'll have kids in school
you got a senior right
correct but again i think her her cost
is going to be around 5 000 a year
yeah
which we have covered
okay we have four years of her school
covered check number one okay box check
one box check two box check three and
then you could play with the variable
jumping in and knocking off the house
and that increases your cash flow
which enables you to pay be more able to
pay to cash flow college
um that makes me more nervous though
than just having it covered and then
reaching over and paying off the house
you're gonna get to all three you're
gonna be wealthy you're gonna have a
paid for house and you're gonna get all
three paid for but you just need to have
a game plan laid out to do it and you
decide you you called asking what the
priorities that maybe the case like i
don't know yeah you may look like okay
daughter's taken care of twenty thousand
that's all she needs so before the next
one gets to college and he's to go to
in-state school and have that he only
needs that okay that's cover we can do
that i mean yeah you can kind of
map it out
to pay off the house in three years if
you want to do that but i wouldn't
put the kid make sure that there's
you're not
walking over the edge of the cliff on
the kid's college because if i'm
choosing
between paying off my house two years
earlier versus paying cash for the kids
college
there's no choice here you pay off the
kids college first
before you pay off the house two years
early you're going to get it paid off
it's just a matter of when so it's okay
but just make sure you've got that math
laid out
i mean if you told me a 200 000 in the
bank right now and you're just going to
write a check and pay off the house and
say okay go ahead and do it because you
can we know we can get to the college
right that's the thing so
but you don't and that's not where you
are so map it out map it out map it out
all you got to do is be intentional here
you're going to make good choices i
could tell from talking to you for 10
minutes you're going to figure it out
it's not like this it's it's just a math
riddle
of sorts and it's not a complicated one
it's just flow
it's the it's that you know here's
september here's octo i mean here's
september here's january you know here's
april three tuition payments or two
tuition payments or whatever they are
every year and here's dorm or not dorm
and here's the school cost today and
here's how much we've got and here's
what the state scholarships are and and
you just map all that in there and it's
there's about six variables and you can
pull it together it's not going to be
rocket science
it's really not it's not it doesn't even
require a spreadsheet you can do it with
you know the calculator on your phone
and your yellow pad
if you want to so it's not that hard but
the good news
you're the secret sauce for figuring
this out not some formula
or or adherence to the baby steps or
something like that you are the sauce
and you've got what it takes to do this
you're going to do it i'm proud of you
very very well done
that's a good call rachel that's a good
deal you're a good dad he's a good dad
your kids better say thanks dad yeah
they're going to look back later and
said they may not like where he where he
lets them go to school but oh well
life goes on
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you've taken financial
peace university you know it's
life-changing
and uh that makes it really tough to
watch your friends and family struggle
with money when you know there's an
actual way to do it there's hope
but you can help them you can help them
change their family tree just like you
did and everything you need to win with
money is in a
financial peace university gift card
they'll learn our proven money plan with
financial peace university just like you
did and then they'll put that plan into
action with the premium version of every
dollar and when they get stuck they can
talk to our team of financial coaches
it's all in there with a financial peace
university gift card this summer share
the hope you've discovered for your life
and that money get your financial peace
university gift card at ramsey solutions
dot com slash gift that's ramsey
solutions dot com
slash
gift
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money rachel cruz is here terry
is with us terry is in san diego hi
terry how are you
hello dave hello rachel thanks for
taking my call first time caller long
time listener sure what's up
well what i've got uh dave is i've got a
rental house this was a house that my
wife and i bought a long long time ago
we moved on to a bigger house and
everything else and right now it's the
only debt we have
about you know 2016 when they changed
the tax loss and they went to the
standard deduction
i went ahead that house had been free
and cleared i took out a loan against
that house and paid off my home mortgage
right now the loan on the rental house
is at three and a half percent
right now i'm 57 years old
and i'm approaching retirement and i'm
toying with the idea of paying this
mortgage off
but at three and a half percent i don't
know if it's the right thing to do
terry how much how much money do you
guys have
just cash flow since this is your only
debt
well this is the only debt or our gross
family income is about hundred thousand
dollars a year we fully fund our
retirements our 401ks i do a back door
roth what's your network yeah you know
where net worth right now is probably
around three million with all of our in
our and i have a balance on the rental
house is what
320 000 okay well you've done a
wonderful job congratulations
well thanks i assume you did not inherit
this money i assume it came from your
investing and saving
exactly good very well done i'm proud of
you good work
so let's first let's first establish
that paying off this mortgage or not
paying off this mortgage is not going to
bankrupt you nor is it going to make you
wealthy you're already wealthy
i understand so this question is in a
sense virtually irrelevant
but it's a fun discussion to have so i'd
love to have it okay
um because it's not gonna make you or
break you is my point
i understand okay so now having said
that here's what i have discovered
um
that uh and i discovered this after i
went broke in real estate
and i love real estate and real estate
people like me that grow up in a real
estate household one of the things they
do is they take you and they break your
risk meter so you have no measurement no
ability to measure risk anymore and so
you just borrow out your eyeballs
because you say three and a half percent
how could this possibly go wrong and you
just borrow on up and on up and on up
yours is so small it's irrelevant as a
percentage of your world okay it's less
you know ten percent of your net worth
or whatever it's not you could you could
burn that much money in the middle of
the freeway and it won't change your
life hardly at all so it's not good
that's that's my point earlier now
having said all that i will tell you
that something happens
when you don't have any debt
there is a sense of release
that is very very real for some people
it's
it's so physical that they can
they literally feel it
um other people it just they start
making a little bit different decisions
there is a weight to this
it's like you're not carrying around a
300 pound weight on your back
but you're walking around with an eight
pound weight in your hand trying to do
everything you do and when you don't
have the eight pound weight in your hand
anymore
you're gonna feel a different level a
slight different level of freedom but if
i strapped an eight pound weight to your
hand you could do everything you do
today all day long it wouldn't be the
end of the world for you but you but if
you took it off you're going to notice
wow look at that
and it's not a mathematical thing it's a
spiritual thing emotional thing
relational thing
and you just don't have any more and
there is a freedom that people do not
grasp that have not been debt-free
until you're debt-free so i would
challenge you to pay it off today
and if you hate it
go get you another mortgage when the
rates come back down
no i would add that the converse is true
not only is it liberating when i pay it
off but having the debt right now
is burglar
and that's one reason why i'm thinking
about it it's not that i can't pay the
payment
but
um
peace of mind has a price too and
exactly the only thing that's
the only thing that's getting me at
three and a half percent i could take
the same money that i have a bank right
now
put it into some other vehicle yep and i
mean if you put it in an s p and you
know over time it typically would
average 10 to 12 percent right and so
you appear to make that spread but what
that calculation does not involve
is the calculation of risk
and it's a little tough to put an actual
risk
math number and just your mental health
i mean there's just something about when
you don't have the payment and terry we
i won't name the person but there was
someone visiting the office
dave when we were walking the back
hallway because we were going to go do
something and he stopped he was like
dave's you all were kind of chatting and
he and and i thought that he kind of
followed from like what i know about him
followed everything we teach and all
that and he was like dave you know he
goes you know what i did for the first
time ever i paid off my house
i know and and i remember thinking i
would have assumed his house was paid
off i just assumed it and he was like
and everything you say is so right once
i paid it off like it just does
something to you know and y'all had this
like that guy had a 10 million net worth
yeah that guy totally could have paid it
off and i just assumed
and he was like laughing like he's
laughing like dave what you teach is
right like
i've known you 15 years how come you
didn't know i was right oh my gosh you
know so it was just such a funny
conversation to over here because i
thought
you don't put a pr and that's the thing
too with money is that you don't there's
not a price tag there's not a number
there's not like a a logical sitting you
know black and white on paper
to point to when you just have when you
owe when you don't owe anything and john
baloney talks about this suddenly your
body feels safe like even if it's a
little bit of that eight pound weight
like you're talking about with terry
that it's not a big part of his world
but there's still this element there of
gosh i i owe something someone else
still has their name
on my life and when that is just gone
free and clear
you just can't put a price on it you
can't put a price on the idea of just
this absolute ultimate piece and you can
tolerate a small amount of back pain
and get to where you live with it hardly
know it's there totally but boy when
it's gone
it's a big deal you feel it it's it's
the same exact thing it falls in that
category so it does add risk to your
life and mathematically the risk does
neutralize some of the difference in the
perceived returns the spread of the
three and a half over what you could
invest it in but the peace of mind the
decisions that are made differently the
breathing deeper the
i have less need to watch the news
moment and my life is just better
because of it and i'm just a little bit
kinder i'm a little bit calmer
all of these and those things actually
end up affecting your health bill later
they do affect you and they affect your
marriage they affect i mean and you
really can't it's hard to quantify it
all in a simple
i know you can't quantify it all in a
simple math formula it would be very
interesting to find out the research of
over a 40-year period of time if you
could do it it would be ridiculous but
yeah uh you know
your stress level
the hypothesis would be that obesity
would be less uh that uh health would be
better and your medical bills should be
lower that would be the relationships
that the percentage of divorces is
smaller uh and by the way you know
marriage is grand divorce is 50 grand i
mean just try splitting your assets and
starting over see how that works very
well building plan and so um you know
that kind of stuff so you know when you
you take out the and your kids are
you know they are they're having a
different experience in the household so
they're more functional and don't have
you don't spend money on uh kid
dysfunction in whatever category that
falls into as often and so it's not say
it's perfect but there's a whole thing
here a holistic view of this that it'd
be really interesting to see how many
millions of dollars that we waste on
debt related problems that are not math
yeah there we go this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 if you're visiting the
nashville area
put franklin tennessee on your list
we're about 10 miles south of nashville
suburb of nashville and the ramsey
solutions headquarters are right on the
interstate you can jump off and come and
sit in our visitor center and watch the
show happen we do it from one to four
every day central time
three hours of talk radio every day and
um
there's a visitor center uh all kinds of
fun stuff to see and do a bookstore a
coffee shop that the coffee's free and
the homemade chocolate chip cookies
are free
oh my gosh they're awesome too i mean
you'll hate them you'll just
you won't like them at all in the lobby
by the way where people by the way we've
usually got 50 to 200 folks watching the
show every day out here and it's
completely free to do all that as well
the luxurious are luxurious a um easy
going
home atmosphere out here you can hang
out with it's great yeah the visitor
center made it feel like
there's like pamphlets and stuff around
no it's just come it's wonderful
it's wonderful yeah no we don't have any
pamphlets we haven't had pamphlets in
years
on the stage uh the debt free stage
which is also in that lobby that we're
talking about thus i was doing that lee
and linda are with us hey guys how are
you we're good how are you good so good
to have you guys where do you all live
grand junction colorado oh beautiful
place
very nice well welcome to nashville and
all the way over here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off we've
paid off uh 215 000 in about eight years
wow and
cash flowed for kids
cash flow some home improvements to
house the four kids
and what was your range of income during
that eight years you know we started at
about 80 000 but then when we started
having kids linda came home and the
income dropped to 40
and now i'm finishing up about 130 000 a
year cool what do you do for a living i
co-own a building automation company
we do temperature control systems ah
very good good
and i'm gonna guess since it was eight
years maybe you paid off the house we
did yes we're talking to weird people
that's right way to go you guys a
hundred percent debt-free how in the
world does it feel to have not have a
payment in the world oh yeah it feels
amazing it's great
almost like we were talking about with
the guy a minute ago i mean how
important it is that that feeling is
there to house and everything man
so one in the world plugged you into all
this ramsey stuff eight years ago tell
us tell us your story so
um
you know
our work we're in grand junction
colorado but we work everywhere from uh
breckenridge over to telluride so
there's multiple hours of driving to
different projects job sites so
my father-in-law um he kind of got me
into the ramsey show
you know the the podcast um and uh
in 2014 when we started this i actually
hosted financial peace and i've taught
nine lessons well thank you and i've had
172 people come through oh my gosh
they have paid off four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
so they are the real thing the best i
love it
yeah
very good very good a super coordinator
wow thank you you're welcome i know
you're amazing like i was with my
father-in-law
yeah thanks dad
you know he's
he he was definitely one of our
big supporters and they were you know
they paid off their house a couple of
years ago yeah
that's incredible well having the goal
of paying off your house i'm like that's
the big one right i mean obviously
getting completely consumer debt free is
like huge
and then when you go to move to the
mortgage so what caused you guys to want
to do that was it you know what was the
thing that was like let's work on the
house let's do it we have it we have a
eight years ahead of us yeah but it's
gonna be worth it i think my dad my mom
and dad paid off theirs um and they were
in their late 50s um and we just kind of
looked at that we thought you know if
they can do it then we can do it um
and lee was a driving force he had the
vision yes and i was sort of i think the
discipline is the big thing though once
you get past that first hissy fit of not
getting what you want
you
are like wow what was hard about it
because i mean eight years for a long
time you guys and we say that you don't
have to go like gazelle intense when
you're paying off the home but you're
because you're doing retirement and kids
caught i mean you know there's other
stuff happening i think i think once you
pass that first [ __ ] fit you're like
okay i can say no to myself and it'll be
okay um and then by the time you get a
couple years down the road you just
don't even care like that stuff that was
so important to you is now no
it's not important yeah and now you can
do anything
i mean now you got 130 000 income not a
payment in the world
that's a great perspective though of the
things that you think are important and
you're like oh i need to have this i
want to have this and suddenly when you
deny yourself of it for so long you're
like oh wow we are okay like we can
really survive without this stuff yeah
discipline equals freedom and the
farther you get down the easier that is
to apply to yourself and to your
marriage and to your home and to your
children and
you know it's it works that's amazing it
works incredible
there was some there were some rough
years there you know a lot of a lot of
overtime yeah a lot of
some extra work in there huh yeah
overnight
working working too late waking up early
yeah so i don't think that's a colorado
accent how long have you been in the
states so i've been in the states um
since 2005 so um about 18 years i guess
17 years from england south of london oh
okay just south of london um
i came over here to teach skiing in utah
and worked out to colorado and we met
actually at the ski resort in utah
and uh this is how it ends this is how
the uh end of the story for the ski bum
thing
that's what it looks like at the end of
the story
he's got he's got four kids and
yeah
i had to give up the ski bummer
we call lee the dream killer hope people
come into these classes and he's like
this is week two the dream crushing
begins
his ski dream was crushed
was crushed with reality
crush the dreams in week two i like that
that's good
that's funny well done you guys very
well done we're so proud of you okay
when they do come into class other than
crushing their dream
what do you tell them the key to getting
out of debt is
i just talk about um
you know with the budget um
kind of
i really like your buyer beware
section um you know
don't go for the bling don't go for the
fancy um
the fancy item you know whenever you
research long enough it turns out it's
really not that good like a black friday
deal somewhere
it really just isn't worth it
and obviously don't take in on any more
debt
and uh
just for everything you can work extra
and get rid of that debt
because it's great to be free well
congratulations you guys we're very very
proud of you and i know your
father-in-law's proud of you yes it's
good stuff and thank you for leading so
many other people
through the process that's so powerful
it's a powerful reinforcement for you
while you're doing it but it's uh has
the uh the side benefit of all those
people got help too so it's pretty
pretty incredible well done well done
sir we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you because that's
definitely the next chapter in your
story what's this house worth
it's about 500 000. yeah you're getting
there huh all right good good good i
love it
and i copy a total money makeover you'll
be able to give that away to someone
deserving in one of your classes and a
subscription to uh membership for one
year of financial peace university
awesome and again you may want to give
that away since you're coordinating them
all the way that's fine we'll give you
some stuff to give away i like doing
that great and you brought uh the new
babe with you and uh who is this this is
josephine and we have three older
children ah okay and how old is
josephine she's seven months oh
very perfect
very perfect i love it good job you guys
she's precious
fun fun fun all right lee and linda and
josephine grand junction colorado 215
000 paid off in eight years making 80
then 40 then 130. house and everything
they're weirdos count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream three two one thank
god
[Applause]
[Music]
man
amazing we live in a culture where
people can't stick with something eight
minutes
and those people stuck with this eight
years those are heroes right there
that's pretty studly
it's pretty impressive
very very well done
ah
one of the uh
one of the attributes of the successful
people who can stick with this stick
with something
even when it's hard you just keep
pushing through attention of a nat out
there man it's unbelievable stick with
it stick with it don't quit
don't quit it's worth it live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give
like no one else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today chris is with us in
chicago hi chris how are you i'm doing
well i'm doing well thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
uh first of all i just want to say thank
you because of the baby steps we've
gotten out of debt and our home to my
wife and kids you've become uncle dave
oh thank you well i'm honored thank you
i'm the crazy uncle
yeah uncle dave that's what we call you
um but uh my question is uh we are newly
into babysit four um and we should be
inducting 15
but my wife will be stepping away from
work to go to school full-time so only
i'm will be only on my main income plus
my side hustles and we are wondering if
we should forego 15 and just do minimum
403 b match provided at my job or should
we still push our investments to fifteen
percent why would you do that
uh why would i forego or why would i why
would you stop
um my wife is saying because uh we're on
the one income um
it'd be kind of tight on the budget
um
that's kind of the reason i i'm leaning
towards the 15 and just keep living
in a blur means like we have been i'm
not like crazy like we were but how are
you paying for her college
i work for a university so she goes full
free oh wow
that's wonderful what's she studying
she's going back to be a teacher okay
and how long will it take her
we're thinking roughly about two years
good good okay and how much do you make
chris
uh with side hustles about a hundred
okay how many kids you got
four what did she make before
she made around 55. okay so you took a
one-third of your income is gone you
took a 35 33 cut in your income roughly
and um
and you're gonna have a tight two years
in order to achieve a bigger goal
which is her goal of being a teacher
and a sacrifice to get to that goal
so i think you can make 15 and i don't
hear a reason to not do it i agree with
her that it is going to be tighter but
that's one of the sacrifices you're
making for her to go to school
is giving up her income and then she'll
get her income back when she graduates
and maybe then some maybe some on top of
that
depending on what she's teaching where
that kind of thing but um
i i don't see a reason to stop it yeah
just to keep going i mean i mean it's
what we teach chris now for two years if
you guys pulled back and just did the
minimum i mean you sound young i didn't
ask your age but
is it going to make or break you
no but you miss out on that growth when
you guys still can be putting that 15 so
there's really not i mean
there's not a reason not to so i would
i think it's the tightness is part of
the decision you made when you made the
decision for her to quit and go to
school
and you we made the decision for things
to be tight for two years
and uh that's not unreasonable you can
do that i mean um
and so uh
it's not like you're not gonna have food
on the table or something else so no i
think you need to stick with it that's
what i would do if i were in your shoes
georgie is with us in springfield
illinois hi georgie how are you
good
awesome how can we help
i was wanting some financial advice i
recently
sold my company and
i have an influx of cash
and was wondering what you would advise
me to do with it
cool what'd you sell it for how much
um i've got partners my portion will be
around 2.6 million and
that will
be before taxes are paid so way to go
awesome
cool what kind of business was it
um assisted living very good how old are
you
um i'm 53 years old
congratulations that's amazing
thank you yeah a lot of hard work
well what you are entering into is much
like you did when you started a business
you're entering into territory that's
unfamiliar thus you're calling someone
like us to get some advice that's smart
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to gather a group of experts
around you if i were you that's what i
would do to advise you and teach you
not to make decisions for you
okay you don't do something because
someone said to
you do something because someone taught
you something and you decided to
does that make sense
so you do need the first and foremost
let's get a tax person in your corner
you have a great tax person on your
board
um i do actually okay good so we've got
we're beginning to build georgie's new
board for her 2.6 million dollar
decisions right okay so first thing we
do is we figure out what your tax bill
is going to be and we carve that out to
the side
absolutely okay
so here's my question so
should i take that tax bill say it's a
half a million
it will be should i you know initially
i'm i'm a you person i don't like to be
in debt i was thinking i'd just pay it
off to the government but then i start
talking about
different short-term
uh places i can put it into and maybe i
shouldn't do that and i should earn
interest on it until yeah you earn
interest on it until the last possible
second
okay and then you send it you send it to
them you don't owe the money until april
15th of next year or whatever the date
is and you send it on that moment
not a day before because we're going to
earn interest on it as much as possible
you're you have zero um
uh penalty for waiting until then
and so you might as well let the money
sit but i would set it aside in a
separate account oh yeah where you're
not confused and it doesn't accidentally
go to something else okay and then
there's three things you can do with
money you can enjoy it
you can uh
invest it and you can be generous with
it we always recommend you do all three
i plan on it and not necessarily evenly
okay and so you decide what you how much
you're going to spend on enjoyment and
go ahead and make a list of those things
what some generosity moves you're going
to be are and you make those some of
those moves uh and we're going to invest
the rest and you need to just go ahead
and lay that out go lay yourself out a
little budget really there's only four
items in the budget taxes
enjoyment investment and generosity
george do you have any debt do you have
a mortgage
no no i completely i've already been
disciplined since i'm yeah i've it's
amazing before i started my business
it's amazing um let's pretend that you
ended up with two million dollars in
investments
okay
if you sat down with a smart vester pro
which is what we call the people that
that we
endorse we're not in the investment
world or investment business but this is
who i personally use
is in a smart investor pro for my
investments
and uh who we recommend all over the
country you can find one at
ramseysolutions.com click and it'll give
you a list of the people in your area
you choose which one you want to talk to
i talk to a couple of them and interview
them but let's pretend you invested this
money and it made uh the stock market
has averaged just a little under 12
for the past 80 years
so let's pretend that you made about 10
less than average
okay
here's the way the money will work it's
gonna double every seven years
you said you're 52 right
i'm 53 53 okay so when you're 60 it'll
be 4 million
if you put 2 million in there
and don't touch it and don't touch it
okay and and and when you're 67. not
touching that when you're 67 it'll be
it'll be 8 million
okay
and it'll be 16 million
when you're 74.
is this fun or what
[Laughter]
it's kind of it's kind of cool but
that's why i was so excited for you
i mean
it's amazing georgie but also i enjoy it
too
i said 600 000 aside for texas enjoyment
and generosity i'm just goofing off i
mean if you you can start with a million
and a half and run those numbers out
you'll still be okay that's the point
what percent of my net worth should i be
in the market
so i already have other money and i
before i even saw my business i had
eight hundred thousand sitting in a
money market account getting point four
percent which is ridiculous that's true
that i didn't work that's silly yeah i i
mean i'm on the market listen 80 um 90
something percent of my
net worth several hundred million
dollars is in two things real estate
that is paid for
and in good growth stock mutual funds
in the market
so i've got a ton in there
and i'm not taking a dime out i'm not
taking a dime out today a matter of fact
i'm trying to scratch together some
extra to put in right now while it's on
sale
and so that yeah i wouldn't worry about
it um if you have other things you're
gonna buy another business that'd be
great if you're gonna start another
business that'd be great
if you're gonna buy some real estate
that'd be great if you're gonna invest
in mutual funds that'd be great or it's
something that you know and understand
but that's the things i know and
understand that's where my money is
hey thanks for calling congratulations
so proud for you
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help folks build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five graham in richmond virginia starts
this hour off hey graham how are you
i'm doing well david rachel how are you
guys better than we deserve what's up
hey so um being my wife we're exploring
we're just in the early stages of
exploring starting an ice cream business
um selling maybe having like a
seasonal uh to start with ice cream
stand in the summer and so
um
there is a business nearby that kind of
does something that we had in mind you
know similar business model
and i went on their website just to kind
of explore you know what they're all
about and found that the owner actually
does consulting
and so my question for you
was do you think it's worth it and i can
give you the prices and things
do you think it's worth it to
do this consulting before starting a
business or is it better off to put that
money just into the business and
and go for it you know what i mean
well i think it has everything to do
with how expensive he is
of course i mean um it's worth it it's
worth it to get knowledge from an
operator for sure but if it costs more
than the stupid ice cream then no you
know so what's he trying
so there's there's three packages
there's two that i think would be you
know that i'm on the fence about the
first one is 350
and so it's uh one two hour meeting and
one uh hour follow-up phone call and it
says just basically getting an overview
of how
uh this person um went from you know the
idea to opening their business over in
the course of nine weeks
the second one is uh one thousand and
fifty dollars
it says they go deeper help you create a
game plan
for your business launch includes uh
three two hour meetings three one-hour
follow-up phone calls and
a one-hour walk through of the uh the
operation that they have going and what
will you invest into the business do you
think
so we're we're we're trying to look
right now it's essentially um
the the business model is kind of
having a a trailer
and then renting out a parking lot area
and having the trailer parked there and
that's the location and then you know so
i mean what are you gonna spend yeah
yeah so probably about three thousand
dollars to get a i'm pretty handy so
we're looking at getting like a a camper
and then renovating it um i would do all
the renovating and you know i'm not
entirely sure how much
the cost of
you know okay so let's say let's say
you're going to spend 10 grand to get
this thing open then
sure sure okay
then yeah either one of these makes
sense to me what do you think
uh yeah and graham honestly because of
the size of the operation if i were you
i wouldn't go to this ice cream guy
because he's going to be your
competition
but if there's a guy an hour to out to
find two different people doing it and
be like hey i'll come buy you dinner
uh and can i just pick your brain for
two hours
they honestly may have more real world
experience in the ice cream world than
the consultant i mean no the consultant
owns a business he owns one oh you're
literally going to the ice cream guy or
he no that the ice cream guy hired a
consultant and you're going to that guy
no no no no this is the actual owner of
oh i misunderstood you i'm sorry i'd pay
350 for that in the heart yes i'm sorry
i thought it was just some random
consultant that this guy used okay yes
then i would i would do that this is the
actual owner i apologize
i would not spend over a thousand on the
ten thousand dollar business but i would
spend the 350 in a heartbeat and i might
spend the thousand okay
what i might do is ask him if i did the
350 could i upgrade the difference give
him another 750 later if we wanted to
add on
more time sure that makes sense see how
the first see how the first 350 does
because i got a feeling this guy doesn't
make his living out of consulting with
those fees
yeah yeah i doubt it and i don't i don't
know necessarily if this you know pays
their bills you know throughout the year
i'd love to ask them that and kind of no
no the consulting is just um enough
people have asked him about it that he
got tired of giving away his info for
free that's all it is he's not charging
enough
so yeah
it's worth every penny of that from an
actual operator yes now around here at
ramsey we will bring in people like that
when we're in a space that we're going
into a space that we don't know it's a
new space for us like we did the
borrowed future documentary we'd never
done a documentary before so what did we
do we called everybody we knew that had
ever done a documentary and everybody we
didn't know but they we knew they'd done
a documentary and some of them were very
generous with their time and helpful uh
for instance our friends the minimalists
have done two very successful
documentaries and they shared everything
as friends yeah with us that they had
done and what to do what not to do you
know this won't work when you try that
don't even bother don't call that guy
netflix he want him talking that's worth
the money if you were to pay if you paid
350 bucks for all that that'd been a
deal you know but
that's what we always do we try to get
people in the business that are now
sometimes there are then there are two
other kinds of consultants there are
other kinds of consultants who used to
do it and they used to do marketing for
somebody now they do marketing
consulting
and they've got a lot of experience and
they really know what they're doing
maybe seo as an example and they do seo
consulting on the side
and they actually know what they're
doing because they've had hands-on doing
it and they're valuable and they're
probably worth it sometimes though
consultant
means unemployed
that's all it means
it's like life coach right if you're a
23 year old life coach
you haven't had enough life to coach
okay so you know i don't you know i love
you i hope it works for you but i'm not
hiring you to be my life coach okay i
got socks older than you
so um
you know that that's that's that's the
kind of thing you're looking for so in
the radio business for instance there
are consultants all over the radio
business and most of them they just were
people that didn't make it on the air
that's all they are they're just
unemployed there's a few of them they're
legitimate consultants and they're
friends of mine and they're good people
and and some of them just run around
popping their gums and they they
couldn't cut it on the air they never
could get a show they got ratings and so
now they tell everybody else how to do
it which is hilarious if you think about
it so the key is that they were
successful at some point or another in
what they're consulting against no no no
they just they just took connections but
for people listening if you're going to
hire consultant make sure that it's
someone oh the key is yes he is yeah
they actually know they've got some
some uh track record in doing something
yeah and and in this case the guy's an
actual operator which is like the best
of the best 100 yes you know that's what
you want you want somebody's actually
got that's one of the reasons people
love our entree leadership material
because it's how we run our business and
by god the stuff we teach you to do in
entre leadership i did it this morning
in a meeting you know i mean it's what
it's how it's our playbook it's what we
do around here we're operators we're not
a somebody that uh you know a tenured
college professor who's never made
payroll and has an opinion on business
so no we actually freaking do it and so
that's what you're looking for is people
with some common sense hands-on
experience i love that question graham
very nice that's exciting too graham
yeah it's kind of fun i know
get the hammer out and take a trailer
and pop it into a
little ice cream stand you never know
man you might be ben and jerry's before
we know it
probably not you might be better
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today hey folks put your dang
phones down
over the years we've substituted having
deep and meaningful conversations for
binge watching netflix or scrolling
through social media
sometimes you can be sitting right next
to someone but still be a thousand miles
apart
you deserve
better relationships and that means
having actual conversations with actual
humans that's why mental health expert
and ramsey personality dr john deloney
created questions for humans these are
conversation starters that will help you
put your phone down
and actually connect and have fun with
the people you care about these are
cards are flying off the shelves looks
like a deck of cards you pull one out
it's got a question you can sit and have
a conversation with someone a group of
people it's a lot of fun we've done it a
lot you all keep asking for more topics
so we took the hint we've got new
conversation cards we've literally sold
tens of thousands of these things but
they're very popular there's a girl the
new one here's the new ones girls night
guys night
dating
parents and teens
and workplace edition
you're going to spend time laughing
together learning something unexpected
and build deeper and stronger
relationships
pick up one or two of our new questions
for humans conversation starters and uh
start having some fun together shop at
ramseysolutions.com
me and courtney dexter house we were
doing some
uh the other day one was how long can
you survive in the wild
so you're just dropped in the middle of
nowhere how long would you survive
i
guess i would just survive i don't know
how long how long the rest of my
life my gosh it's not like it's not i
mean i'm gonna i'm gonna make it
i mean you know see that's why he's not
fun to play with so i know but i mean
what do you want two years i'm 62 28
years
oh my god so i said 72 hours
then i better wave my flag i could i
could like you have the option of waving
a flag i didn't know this yeah like how
long would you like would you be like if
you wave the flag is that when you die
you said survive huh yeah
i'm gonna fight i'm not gonna die
so you know
i'm gonna kill something else and eat it
one of my favorite questions not from
questions i'm sure it's in there is like
if you could just like wake up tomorrow
the movie the family man with nicholas
cage where he like woke up and he had
married his high school sweetheart and
like what his whole life would have been
totally different he was like this like
stock broker in new york city
and then he woke up the next morning and
he had married yeah
yeah weird movie so that's a no i think
it's fascinating so it's always a fun
question if you were to wake up the next
day and be anything you want anyways so
we always ask like we were asking
winston was going to be like a secret
agent right yeah like winston would like
be like a sniper or something you know
what i mean and he will would be honest
bill would like go and be a fish fly
fisherman in colorado dave's like
i'd just be me
well i mean why would i want to be
anything else come on i got a great life
i feel like you're not fun if i wouldn't
me i'd want to be me that's what i'm
saying how long would you survive in the
wild dave oh no i died i'm like this
isn't fun
apparently
you're what you're saying is these
conversation cards don't work they don't
work on you no we got in one of the
daniel pulled them out in a a board
operating board meeting and i don't
remember what the question was but it
ended up being who got the most ticket
tickets
uh speeding tickets
in the room and i had more speeding
tickets than all of them combined i
believe it
speeds
breaks the law
a law breaker every day every day
it's it's um laws don't apply
that on the air i don't wear a mask and
i don't follow and i don't why how did
that go there how did that go there
anyways
follow the speed limit
ian get me out of this please god ian is
in miami hey ian what's up dan how long
would you survive in the wild
ian oh um i don't know maybe like a week
i would say no i'm not sure good for you
all right good for you okay he's scared
to answer you so uh you're scary
so
you don't answer the way you want it's a
problem
all right ian what's up what's up ian
how can we help how can we help you well
thanks for the time i appreciate it um
my question is trying to figure out
how i can best or more effectively save
money so my my goal right now is to to
eventually buy a home
um i recently graduated from college so
i graduated last may from college
congratulations what's your degree in
thank you i studied spanish and
chemistry good good okay
um and so
right now i'm living at home i'm saving
on rent obviously since i'm not anxious
you're at home saving on rent what do
you make a year
um i make 60 000 a year okay move out
okay
um right now
i'm basically pocketing about two
thousand dollars a month and putting
that in uh
you know a savings account but i wanted
to know if there's a more effective way
for saving
i've got some side hustles that i do you
know dog sitting and photography
that's you know some nice chump change
but i i'm looking to
expand that further if possible good and
i wanted to see if you had any any sort
of tips i mean right now it feels like
i'm living more reactively financially
speaking and i want to figure out if
there's a way to be more proactive
i think you're more proactive than you
give yourself credit for you're out
there you got side hustles you have a
savings game plan you know exactly where
your money is you're telling your money
what to do you're not wondering where it
went i mean it sounds like you're pretty
proactive to me what do you what do you
feel like you're reacting to that you're
out of control on
um i guess it feels like if you're
familiar with miami there's the whole
scene of you know you've got like crypto
and there's all this other stuff blowing
up which i typically don't pay much
attention to but i figured there must be
another way maybe
maybe
the stock market i don't know
are you investing at all ian though are
you investing in anything
um
i mean not necessarily i mean i've got
like uh you know my 401k and i've got
you know um i think a money market um
that i share with my twin sister we kind
of figured a couple years ago we wanted
to save some money together why would we
both set aside some money there but why
besides that
sorry why do you save money with your
sister you're a grown-up
well we figured we've we've always you
know grown up together and we're like
why not you know this was during the
pandemic and we were just kind of
sitting at home and figured how much is
in that account
um
i don't know off the top of my head i
think it's probably around three to five
thousand okay and how much is in your
other savings
40 000. way to go very well done okay
here's what i'm going to advise you to
do
the wife that you meet in the future is
not going to be fond of sharing a
savings account with your sister
so i'd break that up today not because
i'm mad at your sister i'm not i think
she's sweet and it's wonderful that
you're twins and you do this together
but i would break that up today and so
now you have 41 500 in your account and
i would go get you the an inexpensive
apartment and set you up a grown-up life
okay and i wouldn't worry about
investing and looking for a shortcut i'd
start saving like continue to save like
crazy towards buying a house sooner
rather than later there's no panic
there's no rush
but sometime in the next year or two try
to buy a house
do you have any debt ian
i have no debt um
and so that is also huge that's all
right that's why i kind of figured you
know i want to figure out if there's a
way to just obviously you said there's
no way to make money fast and i've
definitely realized that um but you know
just trying to kind of
leverage all of the the opportunity to
have now let me give you let me give you
an opportunity you haven't considered
okay from 30 years of doing what i do
personal finance is 80
behavior
it's 20 head knowledge
you are a very controlled and
disciplined and mature young man
well done sir
well done
now
what i have found is
that people when they move out of their
parents house and buy their own milk and
their own bread
and get their own clothes cleaned
and that kind of thing
it does something inside of them that
causes them to make more money
and it's it's a little bit it's a little
bit hard to calculate with a math
formula but it's uh it's like the last
stage of growing up
and uh that's what you need to do
if you were my son
i would love you so much that i would
kick you out
but i would do it gently and kindly and
we would help you get something set up
and we did that with our kids we weren't
mean to them
but the last stage
you're ready baby you're a year out of
college you got 40 000 in the bank it's
not financially efficient for you to
live at home because you're limiting
your personal growth
that's what i'm trying to tell you
and that's what i'm gonna encourage you
to do this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage brock and jenny are with
us hey guys welcome hi how are you
better than i deserve where do you all
live we live in colorado springs oh very
nice welcome to nashville and here to do
a debt-free scream how much did you pay
off we paid off 347 374 thousand dollars
in about one and a half years way to go
wow and your range of income during that
time from 240 to start and we ended
about 350 000
excellent what do you guys do for a
living
well i have a waxing boutique in
colorado springs
and i started that about six and a half
years ago with my daughter when she's
about six months old or so
and i'm a digital product manager at a
financial institution ah okay very well
done thank you well you guys are killing
it well done and decided to uh take this
fabulous income and just knock the debt
out what kind of debt was it we paid off
the house
oh
nice all right looking at weird people
and that's a nice house too
how much is it worth now about 950
thousand dollars
amazing
so i'm looking at baby steps
millionaires as well well done you guys
at least invite more yeah so how much is
in retirement accounts
about 900 000 all right so a couple
million dollar net worth well done guys
how old are you millionaires i just
turned 40 this year i'm 36.
[Laughter]
amazing you guys
oh you killed it incredible a lot of
people make a great income and
completely screw it up and you guys made
a great income and killed it way to go
y'all well done
very well done excellent excellent job
all right a year and a half ago you say
you look up and you go ah we can reach
over and smack the house and knock it
out it's doable you can see the numbers
and uh what made you do that
um it actually started
when we moved to colorado springs um
we've been there going on eight years
now and one thing that i came across was
your podcast when my son was little i
didn't know a whole lot of people
and so to put him to sleep when he would
nap i would just find a neighborhood to
drive around and i would listen to you
and i loved
everything that you taught
and i'm good for putting him to sleep
and i ended up mentioning it more and
more and more to brock and to the point
that brock got tired of hearing it yeah
and then it was just like you know what
let's let's just like hammer this down
and for me it was when we paid off our
cars
we were like oh why don't we just take
that amount that set amount that we
would be paying every month for a car
payment
and add that to the mortgage and
and it just sort of kind of went ahead
from there we had a general approach for
avoiding debt and how to save money our
own like four-step processing that we
had however when i learned more about
your process which is more sophisticated
than what we were doing at the time and
we were also willing to play with fire
to have benefits but those benefits
really are ancillary versus the risk and
then we fully adopted your plan and
fully stopped putting money into an
excess emergency savings or investing it
we decided to redirect that to the house
and now we have no fire in place and now
we can redirect that money fully to
investing
and uh it's it's it's far more
comfortable and your approach about the
snowball and really how you begin to
fire it individual objectives really
helps you to achieve it a lot faster and
i think that one and a half year period
when we paid off our house was
it was a whirlwind when we look back on
it
you look at it as like an insurmountable
task something that would be very
difficult and looking back on you go it
was a breeze but but
it's not something i want to revisit so
certainly it's going back no
off the table yeah
but you're done forever i mean you're
sitting on a million dollar house and
you're you're not even 40 years old it's
paid for and you've got all this margin
now
you can do anything you want to do yeah
the goal is from where from how we grew
up in our experience as children and uh
very fortunate to be we're at and very
fortunate with our two children that we
get a chance to give them
a different life and build a very
different life than what they that we
grew up with yeah so i we didn't talk
about money or anything like that yeah
rachel no no no no you're great you're
great i was gonna just say though you
know brock's you sound like a very
processed oriented guy you have your
processes and all that so tell me like
the emotional side of being debt-free so
we've taken a call even last segment and
the guy was like i don't know should i
pay off my house it's only three percent
interest you know he's kind of
toiling with the because of the math
didn't feel like it so you probably i
could see i would assume kind of fault
can fall in that bucket but the idea of
paying everything off how does it just
how does it feel both of you i want to
know but it feels great like when you
guys ask questions about sort of what's
the how do you do this i think you can
focus a lot on the tools for how to do
something but
i think really you focus on the behavior
components and the prior guests talked
about discipline equals freedom and i'm
a very big jocko willing fan
and
if you have the discipline to do
something you will get the freedom from
it if you're willing to dedicate the
time and the focus to that and a real
big
habit of mind is to break habits you can
break most habits in little of a week
and so i really try and find like things
that are sacred to us or things that i
shouldn't be doing and try and break
those whether it's through exercise or
diet or paying off the house which is
another habit that we broke is like it's
only you know two thousand plus dollars
a month not a big deal right
but that but the behavior and how you
engage that that stuff that really
challenges me and that stuff that i
really embrace i love that overall
myself
it's awesome you guys incredible what'd
it do for your marriage
walking this journey um i think we're
really good team players to begin with
and so i feel like we're just so much
stronger
um
especially now i mean when you can get a
marriage that really coincides
on the financial aspect of it
it really strengthens so many other
aspects of the relationship
and everything else seems kind of
trivial after that you know early on our
relationship um we had a situation where
we first started dating and i took out a
credit card and built up a thousand
dollars in debt i was 19 she was 24 and
i wanted to impress her
one night
we couldn't pay for ice cream and then
we led to a really honest conversation
the first year of us dating we've been
together for nearly 17 years
of
really hard learnings and i look at this
as like a ladder every ladder you get to
a plateau where you get a better view
and a better view and so us saving our
first thousand dollars or us having our
large emergency fund or us paying our
house now our view is more and more
broad so those controls that we had on
money get looser and looser as we get
more control and a better vision for
where we're going in the future
beautiful and so things get a lot easier
when you start letting go of that and a
great example of that i know this is
funny here but i don't care about her
getting your nails done now at this
point i used to now i don't it seems
like a trivial amount but that goes back
to i think discipline and behavior
disappointing oh it's only this it's
fine it's not a problem but and
jacqueline and jacqueline have been
trading ideas back and forth for many
years and it's the same thing
the way we say this about equals freedom
is if you live like no one else later
you get to live 100 get your nails done
like no one else right yeah yeah when i
recommend books i always recommend his
books and your books because
they're life-changing thank you thank
you i'm not there as big or tough as he
is actually he's a big softy really if
you get right down to it but uh doesn't
pull it off well but he is he's a great
guy all right guys congratulations we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's uh where you are
you are one and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away and help
somebody move along this journey and of
course we've got a financial peace
university membership for a year and
that's the new videos with george
campbell dr john dolone rachel cruz and
me and the best financial peace
university we've ever done right now
going out there so give all that away
help somebody out you guys are
incredible you've got a real grasp on
uh the things it takes to win not only
in finance but in everything else you're
a pretty impressive couple very very
well done thank you very well done and
let's bring the kiddos up what are their
names and ages liam is nine and harper
is six all right
good looking guys i like it well done
all right so brock and jenny liam and
harper from colorado springs 374
thousand dollars paid off 40 years old
and less they did all this in a year and
a half
they make good money 350 but they have a
million-dollar house that's paid for and
a million dollars in their retirement
are just under in both cases count it
down let's hear a great debt free scream
one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
talking about a family tree being
changed they did it with an exclamation
point boom
so fast
fabulous this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 9 9
instruct the wise and they will be wiser
still teach the righteous and they will
add
to their learning thomas jefferson said
honesty is the first
book of wisdom
open phones at
825-5225
ruth is in cleveland ohio hi ruth
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call sure how
can we help
well my husband and i have been married
for 29 years but we've always had one
problem extended family
you're the only ones
well my husband came from welfare and
got his college education and then i
came from the opposite side of the track
but both sides of the family has always
had money problems
and um
we've been having problems
understanding what our biblical
responsibilities are to family
and they got so bad at one point when we
were 45 we looked around and discovered
that we had less than a hundred thousand
in our 401k we had 80 000 on credit card
debts and a big mortgage
so we said to our family just without a
stop we're being ruined and so we spent
a lot of years we've had 700 000 in our
401k
we're down to the left 4 000 on a credit
card and we have 11 000 emergency funds
so we were going to be debt-free this
year and our mortgage was paid off
then we said we're doing great then the
family emergencies happened again
his parents are in their mid 70s very
bad health
and ray his sister and her two daughters
all ended up homeless at the end of the
year
so we grabbed a 30 000 loan out of our
401k
bought a manufactured home for them a
three bedroom threw them all in it and
got our name off of it because we didn't
want to be legally
drowned with them
and then just other emergencies happened
and our eleven thousand dollar emergency
fund
um drained also part of that was us we
had a
basement leak so that was six thousand
dollars per waterfront home
i'm 55 and that's what happened how old
is your husband
55. so what are you all gonna what are
you all gonna stop this
exactly but how can we walk away from
family is isn't biblically
you know especially his parents
biblically you are biblically there is
no mandate for you to
support misbehavior
if my
if your mother is doing cocaine you are
not biblically obligated to buy it
true if your mother is misbehaving and
won't work you're not biblically
obligated to buy her food
not biblically
absolutely not biblically those that
won't work don't let them eat paul said
do you remember reading that
yes but now his parents are too old to
work and they're very sick yeah that's
not what i'm talking about you said
biblically
let's solve that first because you've
got to quit blaming the bible for your
lack of boundaries
okay
it's not the bible's fault you can honor
the position of father honor your father
and mother remember ten commandments
okay
you honor the office of father and
mother but not the misbehavior of father
and mother
okay if your father raped someone you
wouldn't honor that oh no okay
you don't so you honor you but you can
still honor the office of fatherhood
okay you follow me in the office of
father the office of mother so we can
honor your mom and dad even though they
have misbehaved and even though they're
now let's move past the bible then and
say okay
from an emotional standpoint they need
some food am i going to go buy them some
food if i have 700 000
yes i
am okay
right no question
am i going to give them a house probably
not
am i going to make them am i going to
make them get on a budget and live
within their social security income
and why as a part of
the me loving them well as an ob you
know if i'm going to give you money
you're going to do what i say
with his stuff but you're just throwing
you're just giving a drunk a drink for
25 years
you're enablers
well we thought we were saving families
like when we paid the property taxes for
his brothers didn't work for children
actually his brother did get out of
everything and now he's a truck driver
and they're doing well okay so you did
help them
you you enabled them to do better
instead of enabling their misbehavior
right but no one else is doing better
okay so what's the the reason is is you
require if you give someone that has an
alcohol problem that that you have you
have a process in place that they don't
spend it on alcohol
i'm using that as a metaphor you
understand right right yes i do all
right so you you're sweet people you're
kind people and and by the way ramses
are kind people we just understand
boundaries
and ruth it's it's taking you and your
husband your heart for for wanting to
help right
you've done it in a misdirected way
um but still taking that spirit of
helping
and whether that's through teaching
whether that's through hey
you're going to go through this class
whatever will you put up
there's a way to still to still help and
love them by not just funneling the
money constantly so who who else are you
who else are you guys
who who is dependent upon you right now
in your family
um
my husband's parents his sister
her two 20-year-old daughter why don't
they work um
they are emotionally
damaged or get counseling and too shy to
interview yeah they need to get a job
now yeah honestly we would have been
okay not helping them but
on it we
because we did say stop when we turned
45 but
then when his parents became too ill
we're like well we can't leave them out
on the street being that ill yeah well
but yeah but if i'm going to help them
they the other people don't get to live
with them
we were hoping that they would take care
of his parents
no you weren't
you didn't have no intelligent person i
already know these people well enough to
know they're not going to do that
and you are you know i'm a lot better
than i do
true they're too shy and they're too
deep into counseling to go out of the
house and get a job and you thought they
were going to take care of someone
you didn't really think that
well we thought if we threw them all
together they could kind of help each
other
oh darling that was bad hypothesis
[Laughter]
we're gonna put a bunch of broken things
together and it's gonna make one fixed
thing
i don't think so
okay so you guys have got listen i'm
gonna send you a book called boundaries
by dr henry cloud
and i want you to lovingly
kindly and firmly
start helping people
not throwing money at them
and helping them means you move them
like you did the one brother-in-law to
sustainability
every move that you make with money has
to move them towards standing on their
own
and some people that may mean not giving
money to
and just letting them be what comes yeah
yeah
magically 20 year olds
magically 20 year olds who get hungry
will go get a job it's magical
true very true they'll bust through
their trauma and
it'll be amazing or they'll end up in an
institution or something because they
truly have a mental illness at a level
that they don't need to be living down
with broken down 75 year olds
right right that actually is true too
yeah so one of the two they need to get
up get they need to paint or get off the
ladder they're 20.
and they're parasites they're parasites
so it's time
it's not good for them
what has been modeled
what his dysfunctional family it's his
family what his dysfunctional family is
modeled to these two 20 year olds is
horrible
yes
and it's done them a disservice that's
what enabling always does it's a
disservice yeah so i know your problems
aren't real and all of that but you have
to learn i mean i want you to love them
i just want you to love them well
and thoroughly and with wisdom
and kindness and firmness
and um all you've done is just kindness
only
and it hasn't resulted in what you
wanted that's why you called the book is
boundaries by dr henry cloud hold on
we'll send it to you that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
you